like I have a similar experience with
YouTubers even is this just like a me
thing like when I become personal
friends with YouTubers and I mean like
and I mean like more than just like I
met you once I think like when I
actually become like friends friends
with people yeah a lot of the times I
can't watch their YouTube videos anymore
not can't watch but you can't watch them
in the same way yeah it's a different
different yeah yeah it's and it's like
you know sometimes people are like just
you know that good yeah where you can
still watch their videos and enjoy them
right even if you know them in a
personal level maybe because they just
have that much of a great personality on
on camera yeah but like I've had so many
moments where I'm like you know what I
really hope I don't get to meet this
YouTuber because I really like their
videos
like I'm like that with uh Anthony
fantana oh yeah I I love that man's
content I hope I never get to meet him
just so I can continue watching needle
drop videos that's what they're gonna do
if you said that to him he'd go out of
his way to become friends yeah yeah
please don't despite you yeah yeah
because it sucks because like I've had
like so many YouTubers when I'm just
like I've loved your content for years
and I've wanted to meet you and you know
and I met you and you're a great person
yeah and then I try and go and watch
their videos and I'm like
just not the same yeah I don't know I
don't know what it is it's just the me
thing I don't think it's just you think
I feel like that barrier yeah is just
gone like when you when you know the
Creator like like you you've you've
removed that I guess fourth wall yeah
because a parasocial relationship
becomes a social
for real yeah for real yeah the power is
so short
comes a real relationship and you're
like oh you just just uh they're just
like another just another dude I know
that and we know that everyone who is
making videos is just another normal
person but when you actually get to know
them and you interact with them pretty
often you're like oh it's just just uh
[__] Chris doing his thing again any
yeah and it sucks because it's like you
know I've I've had the the amazing
pleasure to meet so many [__] awesome
creators you know doing this job but
it's just gotten to the point now where
I'm just like [__] I'm running out of
content to watch bro I can't I can't
watch my friends videos anymore like I
have to constantly be looking for like
new people's content to watch yeah yeah
and it's like and you know again it's
like there are lots of creatives where
it's like that their personalities are
so maybe so far removed from the content
that they make where it's like I can
still enjoy their videos as just like a
product but like you know a lot of
YouTubers as well like love putting
their own personalities into them and a
lot of those personalities that they
show on screen are not that different or
not different at all to how they
actually are in real life right yeah so
it's like yeah it becomes this really
weird thing of like it goes from like
watching just this cool person on camera
that you really admire and like this
stuff too so just like this equivalent
of like if of meat from high school just
started making videos right it's just
like oh this is this is where I think it
would only happen for me if it was like
the YouTube was uh YouTuber was a deep
character and then you met them and hung
out with them and they were like just
like chill oh yeah I don't think it
would bother me I I mean it doesn't
bother me right right whatever the video
is good the video is good yeah for sure
for sure yeah I don't know I feel like
that's just the me problem sounds like
uh you that is definitely a meme it is
it is a lost problem yeah you know when
they when they say don't meet your
Heroes it's I'm like I felt that man
yeah I mean it's It's Your Heroes are
YouTubers yeah it's even it's it's an
even weirder feeling for me
um like not even like normal videos
where when you have a mate who does
content creation does YouTube and then
they make like a serious video right and
then you watch the serious video
um about them talking like this serious
topic and you're like [__] this feels so
weird right now because I've I've had
like you know deep close conversations
with them
um but right now it kind of feels like
I'm reading into like their personal
diary or something you know I don't know
it's this
super weird feeling where I'm like I
want to be there for
the video it's like when you find it's
like when you accidentally find like
their private alt Twitter account you
know where it's like whether you know
they just like use it as a as a diary
and it's like oh I shouldn't have maybe
I shouldn't have seen this I've never
understood the point of having like alt
Twitter accounts for alt any any of
those accounts yeah and that helps you
have different YouTube channels but
they're very different things yeah yeah
I feel like what what could warrant
having an alternative Twitter account
more shitty memes I personally don't
like
I do kind of understand but I personally
don't feel this way but some people just
want to [__] shout things into the
voids yeah well it just vents into the
void uh and not have to worry about the
you know repercussions of some of the
things that you get when you post stuff
online you know
um but I feel like I don't know if you
can't say something online just don't
say it online like I feel like yeah do
you need to post like every thought you
have to avoid some people do some people
I don't get that I don't I don't get
that either but you know some people you
just like tell it like uh me just
[__] sending messages to the NSA
Asian watching me like what are you like
I don't get it I mean it's I feel like
it's like when you find YouTubers or
something when they're like oh they have
an old Twitter account turns out they're
super racist or something
why did they do do this like I have a
dynamite Obsession just gonna collect it
in my basement it's like what just what
are you doing what I don't understand is
people who have old Twitter accounts
that are public
yeah right like if you have an old
Twitter account that's like locked for
example then it's like okay they're
probably just using the Twitter account
as like a digital version of a diary
right where they can just like write
down how they were feeling so that they
can look back on it years later right
yeah but I don't understand ones that
are public and I'm like I'm like if you
want to say it that badly just say it on
your own [__] account I don't
understand those Twitter accounts that
feel like they have to post every five
minutes dude Twitter account yeah and
I'm scrolling and I'm not even on the
next day oh my God I'm like oh boy I'm
like how are you having this many
sentient thoughts in an hour yeah I
barely have this many sentient thoughts
in a day man holy [__] like
yeah if someone does post like eight
tweets an hour on average that is like
the biggest warning sign that's a red
flag that's right I don't interact with
that person
if you start scrolling down and it says
like 40 000 total tweets and I'm like
all right
all right maybe maybe I should have
fallen it's like I understand that
people want like it's hard for me
because I understand people want places
to vent
um and it's like okay maybe I have an
old Twitter account that's private and
it's just for me and my close friends
yeah it's like that makes sense it's
like okay I guess that kind of makes
sense yeah but also in my head I'm like
why don't you just message your friends
like I to me it's plot twist they have
no more than two yeah I'm like I'm like
in my head I'm like bam it's it's like a
weird way of kind of like wanting
attention from your friends without just
being direct and messaging them yeah I'm
not really I don't this could be like a
giga L take I don't know I mean I just
like I don't fully understand it to me
it's like if you have close friends
enough to have a private Twitter
shouldn't you just like hang out with
them message them or just just those
those vents that you might have why
don't you just hang out
maybe I'm wrong maybe I'm missing
something giant here I think you are
missing something giant here okay hit me
um uh I guess not everyone has a close
not everyone feels like they have a
close friend that they can properly vent
to you A lot of the time you know
um I think that is a big thing
especially in the age of social media
yeah
um is that you know you can have friends
online but there's a difference between
you know I'm not saying online friends
aren't real friends but what I am saying
is that there are still some people who
you can might not be able to feel
comfortable around showing your true
self
um and it's so much easier online to
mask different sides of yourself yeah
that's it's it's might not be as easy as
just calling up your mates be like yo
let's have a chat right I mean obviously
it's it's it's not always that simple
but I don't know I feel like throwing a
vent into the void that limited people
have access to is also I think it's the
cooling mechanism yeah it's definitely
something a Band-Aid on a larger problem
yeah it definitely is
I want to understand more yeah like I'm
not I'm not like dude you're a [__]
loser if you have an old account I'm
like I don't understand it yeah here's
my my thoughts on why I don't understand
it like if you have one hey you do you
right I can't tell you how to act online
like I'm not your dad you can do
whatever the [__]
this is twitter.com you are allowed to
do whatever the [__] you want you if
you're posting events you're still
posting like in the top one percent of
sane Tweets in my my mind except for
having Twitter blue don't have Twitter
Twitter yeah then we will laugh at you
collectively
I don't know it's it's uh it's sad
because I feel that like a lot of people
who can't feel like they can't talk to
anyone I'm like [__] man I wish I could
wish I could just be like hey man you'd
tell me you can talk to me man don't
worry about it yeah unfortunately
there's too many people in the world
yeah and then also did you ever have we
ever on those Discord servers that uh
had like vent sections no have you ever
seen these that's terrible yeah that
sounds that sounds bad
yeah yeah yeah I mean again a number of
15 to hit Discord
um they're so they're so bad as well uh
there would be like these like because
you know I used to be on a lot of
servers like way way back
um when Discord first like kind of
started people used to have like a event
section yeah and and some servers well
it's exactly what you think people will
just go and vent but then it kind of
turns into like uh who is the biggest
problem and then who can suffer the most
and it's also like I don't think the
human mind is meant to just read stuff
like suffering or anguish or just those
emotions upon those are just going
through them and being like oh this is
these are real problems and like I think
it just does something to your head
where you're like I don't think this is
healthy to to participate in this or
read this but also people who would go
to those were like desperate and it's
kind of like [__]
what the [__] well there's a reason why
you know therapy is a one-on-one session
it's even then if therapy is also
expensive yeah right but like there's a
reason why one therapist doesn't take
care of 40 000 people you know yeah
right that's the same time often you
don't have mass therapy yeah math
therapy all right let's go on the zoom
call all right everybody put your hand
up one by one let's go through the
problems I got [__] to do like that it
doesn't work like that of course it
turns out I triple booked so we gotta
get through this
it just doesn't look like that and it's
like no but like it it is unfortunate
that like I guess this idea of I guess
like closeness in the digital world and
like social media world has just been so
skewed now so the point where it's like
yeah man I I messaged this person every
single day on Discord play games
whatever but like because there's no
physical connection there yeah yeah it
just immediately doesn't feel as close
even if in their heads they're like yeah
he's my he she is my best friend yeah
but when I actually have a problem that
I need to vent out I just have to take
it to my old account yeah you know it's
it's unfortunate that that's how it is I
feel like venting is a very dangerous
game online
because if you're an influencer or yeah
of course yeah yeah there's been a lot
of Dramas where it's leaked or whatever
and then you're like oh they said what
yeah um you have a private Discord
servers are never playing like the eagle
Eagle drama yeah years ago because of
this drama that happened where a bunch
of uh I guess the labeled as equals
um we're just talking about other people
in there yeah and being very horrible
about it but this is this is pretty
common stuff like these do exist uh I've
never been on one but I've uh heard of
uh them happening before oh yeah yeah I
don't understand how you would feel
comfortable openly venting about other
people in your industry in an open space
I feel like that's like are you dumb
yeah are you are you why like why would
you keep that [__] to yourself yeah why
would you like why would you like leave
that on record as well right like that's
that's what blows blind but it's insane
it's like the equivalent of going to a
pub right and being like I'm gonna vent
to my mates hold on let me just record
this entire conversation yeah
all right so uh here's what I hate about
my boss yeah what a [__] [__]
we all have bad thoughts right we all
say things maybe in private that you
wouldn't say it openly right because
it's just humans and how we are but
you're supposed to be smart and keep
that [__] to yourself so don't [__]
keep a record of it what are you doing
yeah Jesus it's like um another thing
that I I the main reason I kind of I
don't know how we got on this topic but
when I meant like a secondary accounts
or alt accounts one of the first things
that came to mind is sometimes uh
streamers or big streamers have like alt
alt accounts yeah to their mainstream
account yeah but they're still life to
anyone right but they're not on their
main account they're on the whole
account like like the waiting room
accounts all right
um no like the it's actually their
account oh like they'll just be live on
an account with way less followers yeah
but everyone openly knows I I I I I I
think if I remember correctly it sounds
to do with maybe if the audience is too
big on the main they want a smaller
audience where they just play games they
wouldn't maybe wouldn't be consider as
much content as normal right yeah which
makes sense but also in the same way I'm
like that seems kind of odd though yeah
I don't know I I kind of get it so you
still want to play the game but it's not
the game that your main audience wants
to see but also you just play it offline
where it's available to your main
audience
yeah I I yeah I I don't know well I feel
like a lot of streamers I've met uh what
are you saying like that a lot of stream
was like Matt um
don't feel comfortable playing games
offline anymore and kind of need an
audience you know I love playing games
on stream but I do gain a little bit off
stream too but it does feel yeah
work around to like get your brain to be
like this is good still right yeah like
I think you need to play games if you
are a streamer I know this is completely
unrelatable it's literally everyone
um you know I think that it's okay and
you just need to get okay with the idea
that sometimes
you're not working yes sometimes you can
play that game you're slacking off and
that's okay sometimes you can have fun
like I just yeah I think you just gotta
get over it and be like just get up just
get over it and be like hey man some
days it's okay to not work yeah it's
okay that's fine totally fine you know
it's it's yeah you've got to have the
you you time yeah you're not
procrastinating you're not lazy you just
gotta give some down time to yourself
you know what I want to know if is if
you do have an ALT account that is
public please explain the reasoning
because I genuinely yeah I I generally
don't understand like I feel like I did
a big outtake but like I just it's not
from a place of judgment or like what
the [__] would you do this it's
curiosity I would like to know how it
helps in any way or how it makes you
feel because to me and where I stand I'm
like I'd just rather not be online than
post that stuff yeah I'd rather just I
don't know I'd rather write a diary and
burn it probably just like talk to my
mom about it or something you know like
I guess not everyone has that yeah right
or I I I don't know to me I'd rather
just not say that [__] yeah I'd rather
just keep it in
suppress that [__] and then maybe when
I'm like 80 I can tell about all the war
crimes I've committed
before I pass away
you know I don't know like to me it's
like I'm
keeping that in he's just he's just
lying on your death and I mean like I
leaked those DMs
I wish the Lord got infiltrated the
group chat
gear [__] it's like Grandad how could
you what's your statue you're on your
deathbed and you got like your grandson
with you and you're like take this and
it's like a USB stick and he's like
Grandad what's this he's like it's all
the receipts it's all the receipts
I do like the idea of like right before
you pass away you're like I'm just gonna
cause some chaos yeah I'm gonna just
drop some information I'm going out
swinging
I'm not going down without a fight
yeah if your kids are ever like terrible
people you just make the will like a
battle you're just like you ride it in a
way that causes conflict